let me start by saying how much I like
that shirt thank you are you all up in
the reissues and everything that have
been coming out from the estate of
prints yeah for you tighter that's
you're talking about the you're talking
about this documentary no there's like
apparently like they've been reissuing a
lot of stuff a lot of CDs or putting out
bonus material mmhmm yeah didn't jay-z
acquire the rights to his stuff I think
it's through title you might be right I
actually don't know but I will just say
that I'm enjoying all the music mm-hmm
hundred percent jumping in to your
fantastic movie one of the things that I
think that people won't realize is it's
really dirty but it's also really sweet
it has like it's a really interesting
thing
can you talk to sort of talk about that
aspect of it I mean I get what you mean
Emre of dirty I guess it's like it's
yeah maybe journeys in wrong word no no
it's all good but um I think it just
comes with a central theme that it was
not looking for this to be like another
one his quintessential Eddie Murphy
movies whatever that means for the
individual and that he wanted a
full-circle full-bodied piece of work
and piece of art so I think that's why
you're seeing all these different layers
to where it's not just joke after joke
after joke after joke that is real
storytelling happen here and the
mobility doesn't apologize for what it
is and what Rudy ray Moore was um and so
it's sort of a pure unadulterated
unabashedly itself that it's comprised
of many different seasonings one of the
things Rudy stories incredible when
you're researching this when you're a
part of a movie like this what what
surprised you to learn maybe about his
story and let me start with that well
there was no information on Tony my Maya
character so there was a very little
research other than having watched the
several of the movies when I was a kid
you know and being familiar with the
sort of culture of dolomite
which I have my family thank for that I
was surprised to find out that the
people in the movie were largely his
friends we were talking earlier that's
such a telling character trait of who he
was and what he stood for and his desire
to bring his people along with him you
know the further he got yeah I would say
the biggest thing I didn't know very
much about him so it was all quite new
to me and I kind of just binge watched
all of his movies but the thing I really
took from it was he really was selfless
and that he really wanted to create
something for the people and and to
employ his friends by doing so whether
he paid them enough to employ his
friends by doing so by breathing life
and inspiration into them you know mean
people who may never have thought that
they could have been you know me a
lighting designer or never thought they
could be in charge of costumes and had
like yeah never she never never thought
about doing what she ultimately got to
do in those films never you know and he
was able to see this light and people I
think that was one of his greatest gifts
that he could see your potential and it
was a selfless act I already have to go
I'm just gonna say fantastic movie you
both did great thank you for your time
Thanks